if you went to the Past lives Pavilion  who do you think would pop up wait what  is that do you remember the movie  Defending Your Life without oh yes yes  yes Shirley MacLean oh my God past lives  Pavilion and of course Meryl Streep is  Prince Valiant and God Albert Brooks is  you know I don't know like what does it  mean when someone pops up  like you were that person once in your  life right  I feel like I have some weird connection  to Scandinavia like maybe I was like  some kind of like Scandinavian like Sea  Hag  or like a I'm picturing Marty Feldman  the comedian that has the very large  eyes who is the novel Mel Brooks movie  are you sure yeah  um and you're thinking Scandinavian sea  which I think this says a lot about us  okay great but I still think we make a  great team me too  [Music]